so if you don't already know me i am a
writer at santa monica studio
and
today
we are debuting
the
first actual trailer for god of war
ragnarok
um in a playstation showcase
obviously i know this ahead of time
but i've intentionally not watched it
and as part of that oh my god i'm so
excited the studio sent out
our first official t-shirts they had
them couriered to everybody so they
would arrive this morning so it's you
know so there are no leaks so we don't
see anything ahead of time oh my gosh
look at it
amazing so i figured that i would wear
it while we watched the entire
playstation conference i'm gonna watch
the whole thing because you know i
always do watch them but obviously today
i am just especially excited um
about the trailer i've intentionally not
watched it i've had opportunity to watch
it obviously working at the studio but i
wanted to watch it at the same time as
everyone else because i felt like that
would be more exciting for me and to see
it like as part of the whole showcase i
felt would be just
extra cool okay everyone
i'm ready
that sounds like
a cold wind
time is running out
the prophecies say fimble winter leads
to ragnarok
war is coming
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there finding out who i
am who loki is
i will not allow you to pick a fight
with god
i don't want to fight anyone
i thought i loved it i just want answers
and if those answers lead to war with
asgard
maybe that's what mother wants
we do not know what mother watching
well
i don't recognize that dull expression
anywhere
odin's got tricks up his sleeve we
haven't dared to consider what if there
was someone who could help us
he means here
the old god of war in these lands who is
dead
well for a dead man who didn't seem
pretty keen on seeing he wasn't found
if he's out there we gotta find him
come in
what all yarns need to happen to him
it's so weird i feel like i know these
people
that's
the weirdest thing for me it's like i'm
watching friends at this point
[Music]
war is not the only way
stop thinking like a father for a moment
and start thinking like a general
you seem like a calm and reasonable
person um
[Music]
in moments of crisis
panic does nothing
[Applause]
harness it
that is so weird
oh man
here
are you coming with us
oh my god a cart
ah it's so
i did not expect that to have that
effect on me
[Music]
well some of them
wow
the oh god
the thing
okay about it is you know obviously
i'm so proud of of uh
everybody who worked on that and and the
pride that i feel and the excitement is
not on behalf of myself i want to say
that like i joined in november i didn't
do [ __ ]
but i know so many people who like the
amount of time it takes to make a wolf
sled and how hard that is in oh man um
the the
the excitement and the pride is for the
people that i'm now friends with who i
understand how hard they worked to to do
this um being a part of the team and
you know
obviously i work there but it's more
like i said proud of everybody else um
and proud to work with such fantastic
people who put something like that
together
but um
the weirdest thing for me about watching
that trailer
and i didn't expect this at all
this is my first time experiencing this
right i'm trying not to cry
is um
it's legitimately like watching people i
know like i know all of those characters
so intimately at this point
i know all of those places
i know everything about them and when
how they sound and how they should speak
i mean
not in the grand scheme of things i
still have so much more to learn but
it's that was so weird like that my
takeaway wasn't
cool look at this trailer how did they
edit it together it was
um
it was like watching people that are
like a part of
my life in a really weird way like
genuinely like i knew them really really
strange i man
it's not like i haven't seen
the game
oh very very strange very very proud of
everybody at the studio that's
so cool um
it's a very cool thing to get to be a
part of
and um
ah man
i did think that it would make me cry
to be clear
it's just a
wild like when i think of if i put
myself in it again the pride is very
much
for everybody else and how hard
everybody worked and
these conversations that i have with
everyone like about how excited everyone
the whole team was for this is
like for me personally it is just holy
[ __ ]
this is what i
uh do for a living
it is literally my job to know these
these people
and i do
really weird very very cool
and i was playing god of war
forever ago i never would have guessed
you know and it's
i um feel like i have any excuse to be
this emotional but wow
oh okay there is more
i don't know what what else there's
going to be i feel like it probably
won't be too much right
oh man
i hope everyone was excited about it i
don't have the chat on so i can't see
um how people reacted but i'll probably
go watch trailer reactions too just to
get to see it but i want to be so
careful about everything that i say like
i don't even know if
public has names for anything i'm never
going to spoil anything etc i'll eat
them
oh man
in general i thought this whole
conference was really good
and it almost to the extent that i'm
concerned i wanted to play too many of
these games
man
very weird
that game looks so cool out of nowhere
i don't recognize that dull expression
anywhere
it's so [ __ ] weird man
and that was the playstation showcase
we've got more info and updates coming
right thanks sid and i'm in fact joined
by no less than the playstation studios
head herman hall i am really going to
stop recording this part because it's
not the showcase people are here for um
big fan of both these gentlemen
uh and i will still continue to watch
this but um i'm gonna leave it out of
the video so we don't get too long but
thank you all for joining me it's a very
exciting day very weird very cool
enjoyed the conference top to bottom
though obviously i'm tremendously biased
and i was really excited so i came in in
a really good mood um
man
it's like i gotta go take a walk i just
didn't um
i didn't think it would hit me that way
i expected to be super proud of what
um
look what the team did
and like i get to be like oh i know the
person who did that part and who did
that part and who worked on that and
like i just thought
that would be it but what actually got
me was holy [ __ ] it's my job to know
this world and i do and i know every
single
piece of this and what all these
characters are like and who they are and
it felt like i was watching family
super weird i will not dump the rest of
whatever it is
that i'm going through right now
on the internet
i'm gonna go watch trailer reactions and
i'm totally gonna cry it's gonna be
wonderful
um okay thank you all for watching i
hope you enjoyed this video i'm sorry
about
whatever has happened to me here
but i'm very happy
i don't know
i'll see you guys next time bye